Kars is the only Pixar movie that I
don't like and I remember when I saw for
the first time I was sitting in the
theater thinking like my parents are
betraying me like it just felt like that
it felt like I was being betrayed by
some close relative or something that
they were just abandoning me or
something and it felt so weird because
Pixar it made so many good movies till
my story up and I wasn't alone a lot of
people kind of thought cars was kind of
okay but most everyone kind of agrees
that it's Pixar's worst movie and they
made a sequel to it for some reason
so Cars 2 has Lightning McQueen and tow
mater and they're going to this world
Grand Prix this other car is challenging
Lightning McQueen and in the middle of
all this there's some kind of spy
espionage going on Lightning McQueen tow
mater kind of in the middle of it
tow mater is unwittingly knowing that
all these people think he is a master
spy even though he's just obviously a
bumbling idiot I don't want to get too
much into it cuz to be honest I don't
really want to talk about the plot
anymore because I couldn't stand this
movie I don't know I might get some hate
for this I am a huge Pixar person I love
Pixar I'm not a Pixar hater or anything
I've literally pretty much loved every
Pixar movie except for the first cars I
don't know why they made a sequel
through this it's it's completely
unimaginable to me why they did this
this movie is so childish dull boring
unfunny I could count on my hand how
many times the children laughed during
this movie and I saw it as screening so
it was packed it's it's terrible I'm
sorry this was a really bad movie and I
don't know what in the world Pixar did
it's awful now here's the deal this is
why I think that people might be
confused about this - some people really
like the character of tow mater and he
is essentially the main character of
this movie Lightning McQueen is like a
secondary character tow mater gets the
most lines most screen time he's
integral to the plot he's essentially
the main character I cannot stand tow
mater I don't like his character he
annoys me I don't think he's funny I
think all
numerous forests and I don't like his
character this story completely focuses
on him and I couldn't stand because of
that so here's the deal if you like tow
mater then you will like this will be
more than me automatically so don't take
my incredible negativity too seriously
if you like tow mater I don't so I could
not stand this movie if you're a fan of
schmoes know like I am then you probably
have heard of the cartoon cat as
Christians impression of a cartoon cat
who writes movies and just shells out
stupid idiotic scripts and somehow these
scripts get made in the movies he did it
for the first time on his night and day
review and I died laughing when I saw it
I couldn't help but think of that when I
was watching this movie I was like this
is honestly like some guy just sat with
some cartoon guy fire the president of
Pixar this cat just sits down in the
Pixar course too I was thinking myself
that is exactly how I feel about cars -
it's like something just took over and I
was like what are we gonna what are we
gonna put the Hulu supplies like enough
buzz yeah it was exactly like what
Christian said about 9-day and I'm
telling you my gosh what happened during
this movie I don't know this is Pixar's
worst film I almost hated it 20 minutes
into the movie I wanted to leave I
almost considered walking out but I was
like no just to stay just stay to stay
you'll do your review just steak this is
honestly one of my least favorite movies
of the year the only good things that I
could get out of it were Michael Caine's
Spy character he had a really cool
opening scene somebody action with the
cars was was cool but the problem is
their cars why not make Incredibles to
make the incredible suit Incredibles was
awesome good human characters you know
you felt for them these are cars they
try to humanize them but it fails I just
it's so childish and it's just so for
kids but the thing is even the kids
weren't laughing every screening I go to
for a major big movie almost always gets
applause at the end for going to say the
screening I went to for the last
airbender got full house applause cars -
got no applause there are children all
in the seat our parents said were no
applause Green Lantern got applause at
the screening I went to cars to was
silent and when it ended like people
were just like a me
getting up like I really think people
are disappointed with this movie I can't
wait to see the other critics say but
this movie is dull boring I just
couldn't stand it I didn't like it at
all I'm sorry guys I'm sorry for Pixar
how many of cars - one out of four stars
it's one of my least favorite films of
the year I couldn't help but think of
the schmoes illustration of this cartoon
cat that just hit takes over people it
just starts writing its own scripts and
somehow it gets made I don't know it's
just
oh gosh poor cars too